[Music]
it's et social study a quick look at
what the stars are posting online I feel
like I'm at such a comfortable place to
like open my heart Jessica Simpson can't
keep her hands off her husband Eric
Johnson the singer posted a pic of the
couple sharing a sweet smooch another
pair who isn't shy about their love
Billie lourd and Taylor Lautner the
lovebirds looked happy and cozy in a
field of flowers during their trip to
the Antelope Valley California Poppy
reserved I loved it
meanwhile khloe kardashian debuts a bold
new look for spring the star is giving
us Genie vibes sporting a high ponytail
and stunning life Cape sleeved jumpsuit
I think it worked The Fresh Prince of
bel-air cast reunite over 20 years after
their season finale and Fergie gets
serenaded by husband Josh Duhamel and
their son Axl on her 42nd birthday
[Music]
singer takes off her celebrations with a
pic of her mom during their bday weekend
what's even sweeter Fergie's epic
unicorn cake covered in icing flowers
[Music]
[Applause]